ومن جهتها افادت سلطاته لوكاس المواليه
لروسيا ان كياف نقلت مزيدا من القوه
الاوكرانيه الى محور سطوفو باخموت
الاستراتيجي في منطقه
من القوات الماليه لروسيا في لوغانس قوله
ان تراجع على القوه
يعود الى ما وصفها بالخسائر الفادحه في
صفوفهم واكد على القوه الاوكرانيه قصفت
محور
بانتظام بصواريخ امريكيه من نوع هايمارس
في محاوله لاختراق الدفاعات في هذه
المنطقه
معنى الان من كيف مراسل الجزيره تامر
الصمادي ومن موسكو مراسله الجزيره رانيا
تريدين نرحب بكما ابدا معك تامر صمادي في
ظل هذه الاجواء الماطره والبارده تطورات
ايضا ساخنه على الساحل الاوكرانيه تفاصيل
بالفعل ازدهار تطورات ساخنه تحديدا هنا في
العاصمه التي اعلن فيها التاهب الجوي من
قبل السلطات الاوكرانيه والحديث عن حاله
التاهب الجوي وتحذير من هجمات روسيه
محتمله خلال الساعات المقبله في عموم
مقاطعه البلاد
الانذار والتحذير من هجمات تواصل في
مقاطعه خيرسون زباروجيا ميكو لايف ديني
برو اوديسا جنوبيه البلاد كل هذه
المقاطعات بالاضافه الى العاصمه كيف اعلن
فيها حاله التاهب الجوي قبل دقائق من الان
في نفس اللحظه في نفس التوقيت ذلك نتج عن
ما قالت السلطات الاوكرانيه انه الراصد
لتحرك الطيران الروسي فوق اراضي بلا روسيا
وقرب الحدود الاوكرانيه والحديث عن طائرات
سوخوي من نوع 35 للقوات الروسيه وحديث
ايضا عن تحركات توصفت بالمريبه لشفن روسيه
في منطقه البحر الاسود والحديث ايضا عن ان
ااه سفينتين من السفن الروسيه محمله في
هذه الاطناب صواريخ مجنحه من نوع كليبر
هذا وفقا للقوات البحريه الاوكرانيه اذا
الترقب الحذر سيد المشهد هنا في العاصمه
كياف والحذر والترقب هنالك عين من الربا
والقلق الاوكرانيه تتجه باتجاه بلا روسيا
وهو ما دفع السلطات الاوكرانيه يوم امس
والقوات المسلحه الاوكرانيه الى بدء
تدريبات تحاكي محاوله انزال جوي روسي من
بلا روسيا باتجاه الاراضي الاوكرانيه
وتحديدا العاصمه كيف هذه التدريبات
العسكريه همم كانت مصوره وبتت لقطات منها
هيئه الاركان الاوكرانيه والمخاوف في
الحقيقه على لسان المسؤولين السياسيين هنا
في كياب والعسكريين ايضا في وزاره الدفاع
تتعاظم من خطر هجمات او من ادخل ااا وشيك
بري من خلال بلا روسيا للقوات الروسيه
والقوات البلاروسيه ايضا وهو ما دفع في
الحقيقه سلطات المحليه في منطقه فولين
مقاطعه فولين شماليه البلاد القريبه من
بلا روسيا بالاضافه الى مقاطعه في البدء
بناء جوادر جدران عفوا جدران عازله يعني
مواجهه اي تطور لمواجهه اي خطر قد ياتي من
الاراضي البيلاروسيا تطورات ايضا همم في
المقاطعات الجنوبيه متسارعه السلطات
المحليه الاوكرانيه في خيرسون تحدثت خلال
الساعه الاخيره عن ارتفاع عدد قتلى القصف
الروسي في خيرسون الى 13 بالاضافه الى
عشرات الا جرحها وقالت بان القصف يتواصل
تحديدا في المناطق القريبه من ضفه نهر
دنيبر
والقائد او حاكم الاوكراني دعى وجدد دعوته
للسكان
المحليين بضروره مغادره واخلاء المقاطعه
تحدث عن توفير السلطات المحليه منازل لكل
من يغادر همم الخيرسون هذه المنازل في
مقاطعات ويعني والاقامه تكون في مقاطعه
وسط وغربي البلاد الاكثر امنا والاقل
تضررا وايضا القصف تواصل على المناطق
الساحليه في ميكو لايف القريبه من غير سون
ال همم سوق القياده عمليات الجنوب السلطات
الاوكرانيه ايضا تحدث خلال الساعات
الماضيه عن ان قواتها يعني تواصل العمليات
القتاليه على المناطق الساحليه في ميكولا
والمتحدثه باسم قياده عمليات الجنوب قالت
بانها تتوقع عوده او تحرير كما قالت كامل
منطقه مقبل الايام المناطق التي تسيطر
عليها او ما زالت تسيطر عليها القوات
الروسيه والحديث عن قصف روسي متواصل في
الدين برو وسط الجنوبيه البلاد الاساسيه
من منطقه
اشكرك همم تامر همم صمادي مراسله جديده